[Musique]
pour faciliter la circulation dans le
centre de paris en particulier dans les
quartiers d'affaires
les pouvoirs publics étudient
actuellement la possibilité d'interdire
totalement la circulation des
automobiles en recommandant aux
automobilistes l'utilisation des
bicyclettes
[Musique]
vous êtes contre ce projet absolument
c'est un retour pour moi de 50 ans en
arrière vous comprenez la bicyclette
c'est fini c'est fini
moi je préfère la voiture que la
bicyclette parce que la bicyclette faut
pédaler
[Musique]
moi je suis tout à fait je suis tout à
fait pour c'est un instrument très
pratique je pense que pour une femme
c'est l'idéal pour aller chez son
coiffeur pour les uns ce petit cours
pouvaient absolument plus sur qui les
place vendôme pouvait plus stationner
avec une bicyclette très très facile ou
en décompte remplacer les voitures par
les bicyclettes
en plus de ça les mini jupes très
intéressant pour nous
l'ancien on vous demande justement
d'utiliser prochainement la bicyclette
qu'est ce que vous ferez que je le ferai
j'assure une bicyclette
je sais pas quand
ben moi que ce soit excellent parce que
nous allons voir 3 millions véhicules
dans peu d'années
évidemment ça résoudrait les problèmes
de circulation
[Musique]